hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast engineered viruses as
precision cancer therapeutics presented
by Alexander T Baker a PhD candidate in
the Parker lab at Cardiff University
I'm Christina Jewell of lab routes and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots and
sponsored by thermo Fisher Scientific
for more information on our sponsor
please visit thermo Fisher comm now
let's get started before we begin I
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
and click on the send button will answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also please
notice that you will be viewing the
presentation in this slide window to
enlarge that window just click on the
arrows at the top right hand corner of
that slide window if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation click
on the support tab found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
answer a question box located on the far
left of your screen this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credit
I would now like to introduce our
speaker mr. Alexander T Baker Alex's
research is in the nascent field of
oncolytic virotherapy utilizing
re-engineered adeno viruses to
specifically target and destroy cancer
cells he gained his first degree at
Aberdeen University completing a project
on the soluble isoform
of the immune code checkpoint inhibitor
ctla-4 in the lab of dr. Frank ward in
2015
Alex moved to lab of dr. Alan Parker at
Cardiff University where he combined his
experience of protein engineering and
cancer immunology in the development of
new virus arabes as well as his cardiff
based research Alex maintains an active
collaboration with dr. Manish Brad at
the Mayo Clinic developing
next-generation antibody therapies for
genetically defined cancers for a more
complete bio on our presenter please
click on Alex's biography tab Alex you
may now begin your presentation
okay thanks very much for the interest
and introduction now Christina yes thank
you very much to give Co for inviting me
to talks part of this seminar series and
CERN lab roots the hosting today before
I kick off I just want to thank all the
people involved in the research I'm
going to be talking about today and also
to all of our funders Wellcome Trust
Cancer Research UK Alice R&W and ten of
us as well and of course Cardiff
University so with that I will just get
through the talk I'm here to talk to you
today and give a broad overview of Anka
lytic vera therapy and to do this I'm
going to be talking both about the
engineering research that we're doing in
our lab to create specifically targeted
viral vectors to go off to cancer and
also I'm going to be using examples from
elsewhere in the field as well and this
really is just a broad overview so if
anybody has specific questions please do
get in touch with myself or the lab
generally so I'd be remiss if I didn't
mention everyone who's been involved in
this because it obviously isn't just me
on the Left we've got a picture of the
lab group that's based here in Cardiff
in the Henry welcome building and then
on the right is people from all over the
place big thanks to Linda Kok Lenova
right Mount Sanai in New York the guys
at the top left there have all been
instrumental in a bunch of
crystallography work that I've been
doing and of course thank you to Alan
Gavin and John who make up my
supervisory team across my PhD and a big
thanks to Sarah and James as well who
are postdocs here so
question that I usually get when it's
not talking about oncolytic virotherapy
is what is it it's actually a very old
idea based on classical biochemical
exploitation of the differences between
cancer cells and healthy cells it
predates penicillin in fact and the only
dear being that cancer cells as kind of
highly replicative protein factories if
you will are an ideal host for viruses
which require protein replication in
order to make copies of themselves since
this very old idea the field is morphed
beyond all recognition of course and
modern oncolytic virotherapy is more
like gene therapy and we're also
beginning to exploit demonology color
mechanisms involved and there was a
recent review actually that was talking
about how antiviral immunity is actually
a key part of how on lytx can actually
work the therapy and the vectors that we
use are no longer crude wild-type
viruses or even simply passage viruses
as is the case bird traditional but
vaccine methods they're much much more
heavily engineered both rationally and
irrationally as I'll be talking about
later today so but the next thing people
say is that these people already have
cancer and you really want to give them
a virus they make you ill you know
well a not all of them do most viruses
and in fact the best ones you never even
knew you had and the reason for that is
it not in a virus's interest the harm
its host because if it harms its host it
no longer has anywhere to grow so
adenovirus is which is what i'm going to
be focusing on today most people have
been infected with and most people at
worst had a cold a viruses main job is
simply to make copies of itself that's
all it's for it's not there to make ul
and it does this by finding the correct
type of cell to infect it then enters
that cell makes copies of itself and
spreads out so it's nature's own DNA
delivery vehicle
so what do I need to do to make a virus
the therapeutic well first of all we've
got to get to target our virus and we
can do the genetic level by using tumor
specific promoters which are promoters
which are particularly active in
cancerous cells we can go off the cell
surface level regulation looking at
cancer specific markers on the cell
surface and we can also make our viruses
replication incompetent except in the
presence of certain cancer mutations for
example when mutated p53 and it's not
good being able to just target our
cancers if we can't also destroy the
unhealthy cells so we can do this by
immune stimulation we can rely on the
viruses only tick activity so physically
bursting the cancer cells like a balloon
and we can also do this by delivery of
toxic trans genes which is something
I'll just touch on at the end today and
all of this can be achieved through the
engineering methods that we have both in
house and among our collaborators
so what the catch then why aren't we all
treating cancers with Vera therapy
already and obviously there are some
issues of the field which are being
addressed so first of all we have to
address the problems with the native
tropism of the virus so adenovirus
interactive factors in the blood it
tends to get traffic towards the liver
and naturally it's a respiratory
infection as well so it interacts with
the lungs and esophagus and we need to
be able to avoid all of these things
less dial therapeutic virus get mopped
up in these tissues before it can reach
the tumor and have a therapeutic action
we also have a big issue surrounding
host immunity so like I mentioned before
most people have actually been in fact
adenovirus before and the body doesn't
know that the virus that we're giving it
is a therapeutic it sees it as a foreign
pathogen so it tries to neutralize it
and if it does this too efficiently it
neutralizes it before it can reach his
cancer cell its targets then it can't
actually have its therapeutic action and
finally we have the problem that you
have with pretty much any drug which is
issues with off target so off target
infections in this case could be
particularly damaging because if we go
after our cancerous tissue even with a
targeted virus and we share a receptor
with another tissue then we can actually
have targeted destruction of something
which is not our cancer so we have to be
very careful with our targeting pressed
practices so before I move into the nuts
and bolts of the engineering just want
to give you a quick rundown of what
adenovirus is and how it works
so our adenovirus you can see here on
the left has three primary capsid
proteins it's got the fiber protein
which is divided into the n-terminal
region the shaft and the knob domain
would that not domain forming the
primary interaction with the cell that n
terminus links to the Penton protein at
the base and then that interacts with
the hexan protein which is the most
abundant protein in the adenovirus and
forms also a bunch of different
interactions and is big part of the
immune response
so this is the adenovirus infection
pathway as it's understood for
adenovirus serotypes 5 there are many
many different adenovirus --is there are
52 canonical ones right now but I think
we're actually up to a more like 87 if
you include the ones which aren't fully
characterized so adenovirus type 5 is
the most well studied the fiber not
domain comes along and attaches to the
car receptor so names this Coxsackie and
adenovirus receptor this shaft domain
then flexes out of the way and allows
interaction with alpha B integrins this
stimulates endocytosis of our virus
which then immediately gets traffic
towards the lines lysosomal pathway and
results in a pH shift which activates a
viral protease cleaving off that fiber
protein at the shaft we then have
adenoviral escape from the endosome and
then trafficking along the microtubule
network to the nucleus
so we have a bunch of different
strategies we can actually employ to
engineer these viruses and broadly
speaking there are two approaches that
we take in our lab first of all we have
our bottom up strategy which is where we
start with a well-characterized
adenovirus such as a Down virus type v
we then work to improve its tumor
selectivity we then look to D target it
so it doesn't go after its native
tropisms anymore retarget it to go after
cancerous cells and resulting in an
improved ad v based vector
next up we have our top-down strategy
which is the inverse of this so instead
of starting with a well-characterized
vector we start with an adenovirus which
is not been well characterized at all
and then we pan through these viruses
looking for beneficial phenotypes so we
can start off with something then we can
approve its selectivity again we can
then look at the viral interactome to
find ways that we can go off to counter
cells that are new and we can also look
for new viral mechanisms and eventually
we can create a chimeric vector which
incorporates these therapeutic effect
we can actually achieve all of this
through a mechanism that's known as
recombination which is a technology
which is developed in house here at
cardiff by gavin wilkinson and richard
stanton so what we do to alter our
viruses seamlessly is we start with a
vectorized version of the viral genome
in something called a back a bacterial
artificial chromosome which to all
intents and purposes here is a giant
plasmid we then look for the region of
the viral genome which we want to alter
and we create homology arms flanking a
DNA insert which we want to make and
then we rely on lambda phage genes which
are engineered into re coli host strain
for homologous recombination into the
back to allow opping over of that region
that we want to alter essentially a
two-step process but if anyone has any
further questions please do ask me at
the end and then we can go ahead and
culture our virus in 293 cells
this system is enormously powerful as it
allows us to seamlessly alter almost any
region of the viral genome so I'm going
to start off by giving some examples of
the bottom up strategy where we work
with the well characterized ad 5 virus
I mentioned earlier that we have
problems with native tropism so one of
those is integrins as I mentioned in the
ad five paths way and this does assist
with tracking towards the spleen so we
can actually create a mutation within
the Penton protein and in an rgd motif
and make that into an r GE motif instead
and prevent proper interaction with
those integrins and it's kind of
difficult to illustrate this one
succinctly because this is the
effectiveness of this mutation has been
built up across the literature over a
very long time but on the right here you
can see that when we put the RG mutation
into the ad 5 pence on protein we have
strongly reduced splenic transduction
another issue is add five native
interactions with the blood so it can
interact with blood clotting factor 10
and if it does this this forces the
virus traffic towards the liver where it
all gets mopped up there and if we have
all of our virus in the leather then
it's not getting to a therapeutic
location so on the right in the blue you
can see the basis in the ad five hex on
protein which are mutated in order to
prevent this fact ten interaction and on
bottom there is some bio core data you
can see an orange that add five comes
along it binds very strongly to fact ten
and it doesn't really come off it's an
extremely tight interaction however if
you look at the Purple Line that's the
ad 5hv are seven mutation and we've got
almost no interaction at all so we've
successfully ablated both integrand and
sex ten binding so if we look at how
these mutations work in combination we
can see here illustration of a virus
which has both depend on and hex on our
GN h PR seven mutations and this is an
image of some mouse organs who have been
treated with the indicated viruses so
you can see that with regular ad v
there's a very strong blue color in the
liver and that's indicative of viral
interaction and it's not very much in
the spleen but if we add that factor ten
ablating HIV are seven mutation we can
see that a liver returns to a yellow
color and no real viral interaction that
because that fact 10 interaction is no
longer trafficking our virus into the
liver however what we've done is drive
our virus to the spleen but if we then
combine our mutations we can see that
we've managed to completely avoid liver
infiltration and also spleen as well so
those two mutations are working together
to D target our virus so I've talked
about the secondary interactions what
about that primary interaction with
Coxsackie adenovirus receptor so if we
make something called the k1 mutation
which is a 2 residue substitution FP to
EA in the fiber table domain we can
successfully block that interaction with
car so if you just pay attention to the
black Buster now on the left of that
graph
on the Left we've got at 5:00 showing
transduction of choke our cells choke
our cells have no adenovirus receptors
except for coxsackieviruses Apter so as
you would expect the wild type virus
capsid successfully interacts and you've
got a tall black bar on the right with
the k1 mutation it's almost completely
ablated you're really looking at
background noise in the assay there and
the others are controls which I'll have
to go into a fast so we've managed now
to ablate our virus's primary and
secondary receptor pro person so we've
successfully crippled our virus now so
we need to start building it back up
again and finding a therapeutic target
so what are we looking for in a
therapeutic cancer target we're looking
something which is highly expressed and
highly specific so this is distribution
data so number of positive tumors for a
receptor called alpha the b-26 integral
and you can see that in an awful lot of
cancers very highly expressed although
it does vary by the cancer itself alpha
vb6 integrand is a non-core feed to
antigen so it's only expressed in
neonatal development and it's also
expressed in wound healing which means
that in regular healthy tissues in an
adult anyone who's going to have cancer
it's not really present at all however
since it's on our cancers it makes it a
very very good marker and a very
selective marker as well so this is a
model of alpha db6 intagram which was
published a short while ago in the green
we have now for the component and in the
purple to b-26 we also know that alpha v
6 it's not on that table there is highly
upregulated in pancreatic cancer which
makes what I'm about to tell you very
exciting because that has exceptionally
poor prognosis right now
so what we can do is work with something
called a 20 peptide and the a 20 peptide
is actually derived from foot-and-mouth
disease virus and it uses alpha vb6
integration as its native target in
cattle so what we've done is we have
disrupted the loop on the end of the
adenovirus adenovirus loop which is seen
in the cyan here on the right and we've
inserted this a20 peptide which is
pictured in the dark blue so we end up
with three copies of our a20 peptide / v
and nod protein
by doing this we successfully retargeted
our virus towards some cells which are
otherwise completely resistant so these
are bt twenty triple negative breast
cancer cells triple negative breast
cancer has probably got the worst
prognosis of yeah the worst prognosis of
all the breast cancers for sure and
probably a lot of the gynecological
cancers so by inserting this a twenty
loop into a fiber nob domain we can
actually retarget the ad v here so that
it's capable with infecting these bt 20s
when otherwise it's incapable and we can
further stimulate that infection by
combining it with the care one mutation
so we've now broken down our virus so
it's incapable of interacting with its
native cells and then we've provided it
with the new receptor in a new cell type
which is of therapeutic benefit so that
native tropism is gone by the ablation
mutations and then our off target
infection is eliminated by going after a
highly cancer specific marker but we are
still left with the issues surrounding
host immunity so an example of how we
can avoid host immunity is embodied in
some of the top-down strategy so this is
where we work with a poorly
characterized than a virus instead of
the well characterized at five so the
question is if we're going to work with
a poorly characterized any virus which
one because this is follow Janee of all
of the primate adenovirus --is which
exists at the moment and there are more
than just this though there have
recently been described aquatic snail
adenovirus and identifiers for birds of
prey and sea lions and all sorts of
things yeah that there really is a huge
diversity in this family and the vast
majority of them are extremely
understudied so the species seeds are
probably the best study two of these and
add five is a species C virus they're
very well tolerated but they have very
limited efficacy the ease and those
actually some work done here in Cardiff
a long time ago by Gavin Wilkinson and
his team generating an anti ad for
vaccine for the US military species bees
they have low seroprevalence
and oh there is some exciting work
happening with species bees actually
with the na2 syrup color white one story
out of lengthy Moore's lab in Oxford
species these are by far the most
diverse of the adenovirus species and
you can probably tell by the amount of
information that I'll be coming back to
those these species are or small species
they're quite understudy to potentially
car utilising but not much information
out there for them the s are kind of
bonkers they've got two different fiber
proteins we really don't know what
they're doing in terms of receptors but
they are quite common and the species
G's there are quite a lot of similar
rhesus serotypes which are nearly
describes in here so where do we look
we're going to look at an alternative
species species see because as I
mentioned they have limited efficacy
we're kind of beginning to understand
the bees got a lot of information about
the C's there's not much diversity in
the other species which leaves us with
the DS which are extremely poorly
characterized and despite a bit of
confusion in the literature there there
is not really much information known
about what receptor those subgroup these
use some have been shown to use cyanic
acid but most of them it's completely
unknown so these are where we're going
to look
and actually they contains 35 of the 52
canonical adenovirus stereotypes so it's
a kind of baffling that they're so
understudied given that they make up the
bulk of the viral family so why are they
useful what are we looking for so what
we have here is seroprevalence data so
these are neutralizing antibody
responses against the dental virus
infections in various people sampled
across sub-saharan Africa so at 5:00 you
can see that pretty much everyone in
that population has some degree of
pre-existing immunity to add 5 with 48%
of them showing very very strongly
neutralizing antibody activity at 35
there is a species B you can see that
there is much much lower seroprevalence
there and then the rest of those viruses
are all species DS and you can see that
all of them are very low seroprevalence
especially the ad 48 there 26 and the 49
so that means that we can start evading
the problems with pre-existing
neutralization so if we treat people
with a vector based on these things
they're not already going to clear it
before it can actually have its
therapeutic action so this is an assay
done in vs mcs vascular smooth muscle
cells on the left and endothelial cells
on the right and it shows that these
species these viruses are much more
capable of infecting these cell types
than the ad 5 is to varying degrees that
is
so what we can do start exploring some
of these tropisms is we can do something
called pseudo typing so that's the
structure of our fiber and fiber protein
here on the top there and that's a model
that I made it's actually a chimera but
it gives you an idea about what the
protein may look like in reality so what
we can do is we can cleave genetically
that knob the main sequence out and
replace it with that of our species D
virus we can also do something similar
in the hex on protein the hex on being
so abundant is a major part of
pre-existing immunity so this is this is
some really interesting data which came
out a while back now where they replace
that fiber nob domain with that of
canine adenovirus just to demonstrate
the power of the pseudo typing approach
they actually showed 15 fold up
percolation in adenovirus infection when
they suited typed the canine adenovirus
and they showed this in both
neuroblastoma cells so the u18 mgs here
but they also showed it in a bunch of
different cell lines which shown in that
table achieving up to a 33 fold
improvement in infectivity than they did
with the regular at 5 so just by
changing that one protein we've
drastically improved our cancer
infectivity so seroprevalence there is a
bit of confusion literature about where
that neutralizing antibody response is
targeted and it actually seems to depend
slightly on the route of administration
it looks like in a natural infection
most of that neutralizing antibody
activity will be against the fiber
protein however if you do an
intramuscular injection and also part in
a wild-type infection it starts to get
very muddled here there is also a strong
neutralizing antibody response against
the hex on protein and that hex on
protein is what we've got here on the
right in the gray we have the structural
region which really forms the capsid and
sort of locks together to form that
classic virus icosahedron that you get
with the Dino virus and that blue region
is the externally exposed parts
and that contains what we call HV RS
which are hyper variable regions and
these vary wildly between the different
adenovirus --is so since that's the
exposed region that's where we get most
of our antibody response so at five
there will be a lot of people with anti
ad v hv r antibody responses whereas if
you expose them to a rarer than a virus
they won't to see in any hex on proteins
which have eight reales like that before
so they won't be able to neutralize the
virus is effectively so by mutating
those HDR's
we can start to avoid that and that
seroprevalence so one example of this
came out of the barouche lab in the
states and they'd actually progress this
virus all the way to Phase one clinical
trial now as a vaccine vector for HIV
what they've done is they've taken at
five and they've mutated its HIV are
regions to look like those of adenovirus
48 and I won't go into the clinical
trials it's not really my data to
present but they think show some really
exciting stuff there and I'll just be
talking about slightly earlier paper
from the beginning of the development of
this ad 5nv
48 virus so on the left here we have
mice which are naive for adenovirus ik
is adenovirus infection apology on the
right we have mice which has been pre
exposed to add v so they have anti ad v
immunity so at the top what they've done
is they've made these viruses so that
they express HIV gag protein and they're
trying to assess how much of an immune
response they raise against gag after
administration with these viruses so on
the Left we have regular ad 5 in the
middle we have ad 5 which has only one
of the HV RS change for that about 48
and on the right we have ad 5 which has
all of its HIV RS changed for that of at
48 so in the naive Mouse all those
viruses produce a strong anti gag immune
response as assessed by an ALICE BOTS
assay with interferon gamma response and
on the right we can see that the
pre-existing ad v immunity is completely
neutralized the ad 5 and the HTML 48
one virus but the HTML 48 one 7 virus
that's the one with all of the changed
HIV ours has successfully provided nante
gag immunity because it's not been
neutralized before you can have a
therapeutic action the bottom two here
showed two doses of virus again
expressing that but these are measuring
cytotoxic t-cell responses so in the
naive mice we have a very strong
response at the high infectious dose in
all the viruses and that the low
infectious dose 10 to the 7 VP at 5 and
at 5 hv are forty eight one two seven
are having that successful immunogenic
activity with gag protein however if we
look again at our pre stimulated mice
the ones which have already seen at five
we can see the high enough dose we
managed to get a response against the to
control viruses at 38 and at 48 so 35
and 48 we also managed to get one with
our HP are 48 virus but add 5 is
completely neutralized even at that high
dose excitingly though because you don't
want to go giving people more virus than
you need to at the lower dose at 5 hvl
48 is still immunogenic and producing
that cytotoxic t-cell response against
HIV c
against HIV gag protein so it looks like
that HP on pseudo-scientific approach is
a very successful method of evading
immune seroprevalence and this is
actually something which we are
exploring in our lab with other viruses
as well both for cancer applications and
for vaccine applications as well
so though we always manage to ablate
elvirus is natural tropism and provide
it with a therapeutic one and now we
found a way to avoid the problems with
pre-existing immunity as well so we've
managed to target our virus we've
managed to deliver it to our therapeutic
point so how are we going to actually
destroy these cancer cells so I'm only
going to touch on this briefly because
it's a whole presentation in and of
itself but there are three broad
modalities we can go for here we can get
enhanced viral Isis by using tumor
specific promoters and we rely on the
viruses preferential replication in
those cancer cells under that control of
that tumor specific promoter to pop
those cancer cells we can also recruit
the immune system by having our viruses
encode stimulatory antigens and then we
can actually change the immunological
makeup of our tumor as well by
expressing antibodies against immuno
oncology targets so we can actually turn
the virus into a triple threat we can
restore healthy phenotypes by targeting
those immuno oncology targets we can go
for a selective replication of the
therapy at point of need by using two
aesthetic promoters and the viruses
innate preference for cancer cells and
we can also express toxic transgenes
then we can go for enhanced immune
recruitment as well both relying on the
virus's own nature as a foreign pathogen
so it's going to present viral antigens
on MHC but also we can bring in
transgenic antigens to further recruit
the immune system
so to summarize everything that I've
been talking about today we've got this
recombinant technology which is
enormously powerful it makes us able to
engineer a virus almost without limits
and the only real the only real
consideration is that the virus has to
still be able to assemble itself and not
able to package DNA not chain excessive
105 percent of its original genome size
which is around 30 thousand base pairs
we've hopefully I've convinced you that
these viruses can be engineered target
tissues of our predetermination and also
unless I think is a really important one
we require a very detailed knowledge of
the basic virology that underpins these
viruses in order to go through rational
design there are irrational designs
using directed evolution and that's how
that and a to sorrows collide one story
works and but I've not really gone into
that one today however those still
require proper knowledge of the viruses
even to just decide which ones you're
going to perform a directed evolution
experiment with I've also discussed how
we can really target any mechanism on
the cancer cell with these viruses if
it's cancer specific it can be a very
therapy target because we don't just
have to rely on extracellular targets we
can also manipulate the viruses genetic
regulation to force proper regulation
and up regulation of a virus within the
cell itself and this is strategy which
is employed with a lot of DSV viruses
which are in development and that's
testicular Stamatis virus and I've
talked about how these viral vectors can
have their therapeutic effect in several
different modalities both physically
lytic agent replicating within them
within these cancer cells as delivery
vehicles for therapeutics transgenes and
as a tool for immunotherapy as well
and with that I just wanted to leave
everyone with a list of the citations
and that I put throughout this and talk
so please have a look at those papers if
anything is a particular interest and
finally I just like to thank our lab
funders and everyone who's been involved
with the work that's been going on in
our lab that I've been discussing today
and with that thank you again to lab
loot lab roofs for hosting and thank you
for the invitation
bye Gib ko I'll be taking questions now
so that's great thanks very much
thank you Alex for that informative
presentation we're now ready to start
our live Q&A portion of our event and I
just want to remind our audience members
how to do so just simply type them into
the ask a question box that is beneath
Alex's bio picture and type your
question in and hit Send we'll answer as
many of our questions time permitting
and if we do run out of time before we
get to your questions that will be
answered via email following the
presentation okay let's get started
Alex we have so many questions coming in
but I'd like to start with this one
where do you see the field heading in
the future yes oh that's a pretty common
question I think it sound very cliche
but in some ways were already there
actually because for a very long time
the field has been focused only on only
on safety there was a very high profile
death in a clinical trial in the late
90s which has set the field back a very
long way but now we've kind of been
vindicated we went we all went back to
the drawing board I say we I wasn't
really in the field then but we all went
past the drawing board we rebuilt these
viruses from the ground up for extreme
safety and that's now been achieved and
we've actually had a clinically approved
oncolytic virus for the first time last
year that some Tamila gene led para
vector P back so we're shifting focus
now towards efficacy so there's a lot of
trials right now in combinations of
oncolytic virotherapy with existing
chemotherapy agents but what we're
working towards in our lab is towards
mono therapies with virus so I think
we're just going towards enhanced
efficacy enhance specificity for our
cancers and whilst of course maintaining
that safety aspect so I think the
directed evolution approaches showed a
lot of promise but with the enhanced
understanding that we're gaining from
these new studies we can really move
towards rationally to rationally
designed and extremely ethicist viruses
in our next-generation therapeutics and
with the understanding of clinical
trials and our increasing understanding
of cancer genetics and immunology we can
combine these amino logical mechanisms
with our viruses to fully exploit the
host immune system and create that
Triple Threat virus that I mentioned at
the end there
question from Nigel he would like to
know where are these viruses sourced
from that's actually kind of a broad
question so the so yeah the what's its
name
yeah the viruses themselves are isolated
in the wild there are a handful of
people who go around characterizing rare
and weird viruses when they do they
apply for taxonomic identification of
them and they get fully I'm classified
so we've got 52 fully classified adeno
viruses at the moment but there's 86
candidates as well and they all get
deposited in various bio banks around
the world so if we want to work with a
specific strain then we either have to
go with the people who have just
discovered it and isolated it or we have
to go and just buy it from a bank if you
mean where the therapeutic virus is
sourced from they all have to go through
GM pre grade production size good
manufacturing practice to make sure that
they're manufacturing in the absence of
any toxins and fully traceable so that
they really their drugs that drugs grade
virus I hope that answers the question
thank you Alex now this question is two
parts first did you or anyone else ever
try this treatment in pancreatic cancer
because in pancreatic cancer the stroll
barrier is the major hindrance for the
immune system on the attack also since
it's the cd8 and the cd4 t-cell mediated
immune response
do you see preference or grand-slam
response along with the if'n gamma
response right I'll be a hundred percent
honest I have not been running the
pancreatic cancer experiments myself
it's been performed in both our lab by
our postdoc and also in the lab of
Gunnar Holden spirit of signing actually
we published in combination with Gunnar
Holden today on the use of a virus which
we made using our vector technique in
combination with Gunnar's approach using
tumor specific promoters so please have
a look at that paper it literally just
went out this morning and that will
definitely talk more about this as far
as the immune response goes with still
early days so we need to better
characterize these viruses in the
presence of immunological markers and we
need to perform T cell killing assays to
proper assess this as I said I'm not the
best person to answer that question so
if you would like to know more about
that I think my LinkedIn is attached to
my profile on lab routes please send me
an email and I'll get you a better
answer
okay our next question cancer therapy is
administered over long periods
addressing pre-existing immunity through
mutation it's all well and good but
these viruses are still prone to
acquiring immunity
I always adapted immunity address yes
that's that's a really good question
so there are a couple different answers
to that
first off acquired immunity takes time
to develop so if we have a virus which
is sufficiently a focus then it should
be able to infect everywhere that we
need it to to have its primary response
very quickly so that will be way faster
than we should possibly raise an
adaptive response against it so we'll be
able to get to our we'll be able to get
to our therapeutic action site long
before that develops and it will have
many many days in order to actually have
it serviced effect and life those cells
the other side of it is that as I said
we've we've moved on from this idea of
viruses as a purely lytic agent so we
are talking about engaging host immune
response as well so hopefully what we
can do is we can promote immune action
against the cancerous tissue which will
then create a more lasting anti-cancer
effect long after the initial infection
is subsided the other answer is that we
can evade immune response in many other
ways as well
so follow-up treatments can be performed
with different viruses as well so if we
really perfect this methodology of
cloaking from the immune system then we
wind up with a battery of different
viruses which can all act in the same
way but we will have different immune
immune epitopes yes so it's a
combination effect basically
very good okay let's see how do you
think there are any dangers involved in
administering a virus capable of evading
the immune system that's another really
common question and it's obviously very
valid
it depends on what you mean by evade
because there are many considerations
take into account so a lot of people
will have it will add immune stimulatory
agents and I know people have in the
past expressed concern with combining
and immune evading combining sorry an
immune evading virus with an immune
stimulatory virus because the potential
implication of that is runaway
autoimmunity so these things need to be
very specifically targeted and carefully
regulated the way that we retain safety
is by making sure that our viruses are
ultra specific so as long as we are not
seeing um prolific off-target effects
then we should isolate that immune
response to the tissues where it's
actually wanted I the cancerous and
unhealthy ones the other thing we can do
is a he's rented these viruses
replication incompetent so instead of
becoming a replicated virus and acting
like a virus they act purely as a DNA
shuttle so we have our virus it doesn't
even have to have a virus genome if we
really packaged it packaged it right
although that's not been tried just yet
that's my speculation but we can use
these things as a magic bullet so they
just turn up at the cancer sites
specifically deliver their genetic
payload and express therapeutic trans
genes and we can include anything we
like in that really within within the
size constraints placed on us by the
viral genome so yes there are dangers if
it's done badly but all of these will be
addressed long before these things ever
seen a never see clinic
Alex we have some attendees who um
they'd like to know how do you enhance
immune response to the transgene but not
the virus right so that can be achieved
and it's these viruses are very new but
by encoding certain antigens you can
raise an immune stimulatory response so
the obvious one will be the new immuno
oncology targets so you could add immune
checkpoint inhibitors so you could have
your virus perhaps expressing antibodies
or peptides which will inhibit this
effect or you can actually encode
proteins which will allow MHC to express
immune stimulatory peptides so there are
many cancer neo antigens which have been
described such as v t4 which has been
trialed by yet so there's a drug called
trove acts which was recently tried in
Cardiff as well by the god-king group
who work upstairs for me and they saw
some really exciting results with that
so hopefully by combining some of these
existing treatments and also by
exploiting some new mechanisms we can
achieve that also the virus itself is
not always completely exposed so the
only part of the virus which the immune
system can see is that external capsid
so I showed that image of the hex on
protein I'll just pull up the slide
there shall be loading so that blue
section of the hex on protein is exposed
to the external environment so you would
expect our immune system to raise a
response against that however that grey
system gray section sorry is hidden from
the virus and from the immune system
when it's actually as an intact virus
however once it goes into a cell it's
still a foreign protein but then it gets
spliced up and expressed on MHC and
everything else so we're still seeing an
expression of our own antigens from the
cell surface even though the virus
itself is cloaked
Alex you
do you believe that virus therapy is
suitable for all cancer types
question to answer because every cancer
is unique I'm I'm sure I'm preaching to
the choir here but cancer is not one
disease cancer as many diseases so being
able to make a broad statement saying
that every cancer is going to be
treatable with one mechanism I think I
would probably be lying that said with
sufficient amount of engineering we can
pick cancers off one by one by using
mechanisms which are specific to each of
them so I think so long as there is a
mechanism by which we can specifically
target that cancer type then we should
be able to raise a very therapy against
it we just have to be careful in how we
do it I am sure and well I know for a
fact some cancers are more resilient
than others so some of them will lend
themselves very nicely towards targeting
so for example I showed on one of the
slides the list of various cancers which
Express alpha zb-26 just pull that slide
up yes so I I know pancreatic cancer
many of them express it but then others
don't sorry I'm not being up there we
are
okay so cervical cancer the vast
majority of them express alpha v v26 so
perhaps a virus targeted in that method
will be very efficacy in most cervical
cancers however if we look at liver
cancer there we see none of them were
after the v6 positive so that virus
would be an inappropriate therapy yeah
so the answer is honestly it depends
okay thanks Alex at what stage of the
cancer do you think this treatment will
be more efficient right so there's a few
things to consider there I am tempted to
say as always earlier is better because
the earlier you detect cancer the fewer
cancerous cells you have to destroy
giving a therapy maximum maximum
efficacy one of the really nice things
about on Kalitta cryotherapy though is
that our viruses of replicative agents
so what can happen is so this is the
dream scenario where we've completely
evaded neutralization we will be able to
inject person insert intravenously with
our virus it shoots off spreads all
around the body but is only capable of
infecting our cancerous cells once it
infects our cancer cells it's probably
going to go to the main the primary
tumor first of all because that's the
biggest site
so most of iris is going to get mopped
up they're assuming we have a we have
sufficient extra vascularization in
order for our virus to actually infect
it once it's there we should see
widespread lysis within that within that
primary tumor which will then produce
more and more progeny variants which
will reenter the bloodstream and
hopefully would be able to then wears
off around the bloodstream and hit any
metastases as well so assume you cancer
is not so advanced that you the
therapies traumatic or anything like
this then I said therapy assuming the
disease is not so advanced that the
therapy is in itself traumatic we should
be able to go off the metastasis so I
would say earlier is better but not
necessarily a barrier
thank you Alex and we have some great
questions coming in from our attendees
and let's go with this one will this
treatment be capable to achieve a cure
as a mono therapy or would it be used as
a supplement to other traditional cancer
treatments such as surgery chemo
radiation
right so yeah I'm at the moment the
therapy is largely being considered in
combination
that's because currently the field has
been so focused on safety for so long
that we've actually made our viruses
kind of too safe they aren't necessarily
that lytic at the moment in the cancer
on their own however they do seem to be
very good at making our cancer cells
vulnerable so if we hit them with
complimentary chemotherapy agents we can
achieve that oncolytic effect but not as
a mono therapy that's starting to change
now because as I said said earlier the
field is sort of shifted focus and we're
talking about using this as a mono
therapy now again this is going to be a
cancer specific effect because the
mechanism by which you target it and
everything is going to impact the rate
of replication of the virus the
specificity of replication etc so it
will be a cancer dependent response for
example if we target things using cell
surface markers we can probably force a
greater number of viruses into our tumor
achieving a more potent lytic effect but
it perhaps and this is very much a
perhaps with genetic targeting we would
see that entry in many other cells but
only replication in our cancer ones
which means that less actual viral
copies enter our cancer cells in the
first place so perhaps it might be a bit
might be a more protracted effort in
order to achieve sufficient viral
replication for lysis
what could be the mode of drug delivery
right so at the moment we generally I
say we I don't run clinical trials I'm
on the bench monkey but yeah we tend to
use interim intramural delivery because
we don't have to worry about these
issues that I described with
pre-existing immunity as much because
these things are never exposed to the
bloodstream prior to their entry into
the tumor but as I mentioned where we're
really heading is towards intravenous
delivery because that allows us to get
systemic administration of our
therapeutic virus and to really reach
every aspect of this and I can't say too
much about this at the moment but
watch our labs publications in the next
couple of months
thank you Alex we have time for just a
few more questions can you tell me a
little bit more about the recombination
technology that you mentioned previously
yeah sure
so I'm actually quite glad for an
opportunity to talk about this because
it's incredibly powerful technology and
as far as I'm concerned everyone should
be using it
so traditionally viruses are engineered
by vectorization of the genome in a
plasmid and then standard cloning
techniques restriction enzyme digests
are used to alter the viral genome
however restriction digests are only
available against certain sites and once
there are type 2 methods available they
don't really they don't resolve the
problem when you have such a massive
viral genome and so what this allows is
a homology based cloning technique
whereby we can generate a cassette which
is specific against any aspect of our
answer against any DNA site within our
giant plasmid our bacterial artificial
chromosome so that means that any region
of our viral genome is up for
modification with no additional steps so
first of all we create homology arms so
short sequences of DNA which are
homologous to the area of the virus
which we want to modify and between
those arms we have a cassette which
allows us to make sure that we've we've
integrated our DNA into the correct
place that we put that setting we use
antibiotic selection to make sure that
our cassette has gone in and then we use
the same homology arms again but this
time with our edited sequence whatever
that may be
to insert a mutation at the site we wish
as at the sites where that cassette now
is so it's first cut and then stick and
then we do that again
the cut and stick out our marker and
stick in our mutant gene and we can do
that at any site we can change the size
of the genes as well d'etre et cetera
yes that was actually developed some
years ago now by
I am dr. Richard Stanton and Gavin
Wilkinson at Cardiff and it's since been
adopted by labs all over the world
actually
but applications do you think these
vectors have beyond cancer so beyond
cancer is an interesting question and I
start to tread on the toes of the gene
therapists then there is an emerging
well some people probably resent me
saying emerging field but there's a
field called Oh cancer cancer gene
therapy as well which works more like
treating cancers and magic bullets as I
mentioned earlier so using these viruses
as shuttle vectors rather than as
oncolytic agents the sky's the limit
with viral engineering there are
enormous efforts out there at the moment
to engineered DNA delivery vehicles from
the ground up and the closer they get to
an effective DNA delivery vehicle the
more their constructs start to look like
viruses with things like decorated
Lipper's ohms and encase and DNA which
is encased in various chemicals and
proteins so if you consider that a virus
is really just the mechanism of
delivering DNA to where you want it to
be it opens you up to everything because
you can then change the very makeup of
yourselves from the outside obviously
that is potentially dangerous you don't
want to introduce to generating
mutations you don't want to cause
disease but you can have corrective
mutations as well which is what people
are doing with general associated
viruses and many others and lengthy
vectors and everything at the moment so
any application where you want some DNA
an engineered virus is probably your
best candidate
you
ALX chemotherapy is known as you know to
make many patients immunosuppressed
would that affect the efficacy of the
viruses in its attempt to hijack the
immune system if used in conjunction
with chemotherapy
right so that's where the triple threat
that I was talking about um comes in so
if you are working with virus which work
purely by immune stimulation so one of
those magic bullet therapies are talking
about although even that's not entirely
even though that's not entirely a
monotherapy in itself then you would
have some problems there because you
would have no method of cancer cell
killing without the immunity however the
virus itself is also a little also
elliptic agent so if there is absolutely
no new response then our virus is still
going to be replicating within those
cancerous cells specifically in the
cancerous cells as well might I add so
it's only going to it's only going to
spread from there unchecked so you're
not going to see
I am not being very eloquent here right
so what you're going to see is your
virus is still continuing to replicate
and lies those cancerous cells even in
the absence of an immune response and
there's no immune response to suppress
the viral spread but that's not a
problem because our virus has been
rendered specific for cancer cell
replication so it will still have
therapeutic action even in the absence
of the immune system but again this is
where we come back to that idea of
cancer specific various therapies
because it depends entirely on your
cancers makeup how your virus is going
to actually impact it
Alex we have time for one more question
and I'd like to end with this one
do you think that there are any dangers
involved in administering a virus
capable of evading the immune system
I think I answered a similar question
earlier actually yes so if your virus
was poorly engineered yes but
your virus also let's start with these
viruses are not super pathogenic agents
we're not talking about the stuff that
you see on the news we're talking about
stuff which maybe gives you a sniffle so
whilst of course these things are more
dangerous if you are completely
immunocompromised and everything else
because they can they can continue
replicating unchecked and that would be
a problem however our viruses are
engineered in such a way that normal
healthy cells are completely able to
either suppress these viruses but more
to the point they don't even get
infected in the first place so if a
virus is not able to infect healthy
cells and your virus is not able to
replicate in healthy cells you've got a
double layer of protection against these
things even in the absence of an immune
response so
all of these things are addressed
preclinically as well but the safety
mechanisms are already in place and we
are vindicated in that these things do
work with the now approved or therapy
tea back
thank you again Alex for this great live
Q&A session do you have any final
comments that you would like to leave
our audience with um no not really young
I just like to say thank you very much
for the opportunity to speak today and
it was brilliant get some really
interesting insightful questions there
please do get in touch with us if you
have any further questions I'm more than
happy to more than happy to answer any
other questions by email and if you have
any other ideas please do comment for us
you've been brilliant thank you
I would like to once again thank mr.
Alexander T Baker for his presentation
and his important research I'd also like
to thank lab roots and thermo Fisher
Scientific for making today's
educational webcast possible now before
we go I want to remind everyone that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through July 2018
you will receive an email from lab roots
alerting you when this webcast is
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that's all for now and we thank you for
joining us and hope to see you again
soon goodbye